suite. À peu près tout le monde,
bien avant le 24 juin, pourra
recevoir sa première dose.
- Moi, j'ai hâte que ce soit
rendu à 40.
- Le moment tant attendu est
enfin arrivé.
- J'ai très, très hâte de me
faire vacciner, très hâte que
ma soeur et mon copain soient
vaccinés aussi.
- Après des mois d'attente, la
vaccination sera progressivement
ouverte au grand public
dès cette semaine.
- Maintenant, il n'y a plus
aucun doute, on va réaliser
notre objectif du 24 juin.
- À compter de demain,
les 50-59 ans pourront
prendre rendez-vous en ligne.
Les 45-49 le pourront le 3 mai,
les 40-44 le 5 mai, et ainsi de
suite jusqu'aux 18-24 le 14 mai.
- Le ciel commence à se dégager
et on commence vraiment à voir
les rayons de soleil.
- Au cours des 5 prochaines
semaines, plus de 2,5 millions
de doses sont attendues,
essentiellement en provenance
de Pfizer et de Moderna.
Pour injecter toutes ces doses,
1000 vaccinateurs de plus ont
été formés en une semaine et
une dizaine d'entreprises seront
mises à contribution dès lundi.
On reverra aussi les horaires
des centres de vaccination.
- Avec des clientèles plus
jeunes, qui sont sur le marché
du travail, on va s'assurer
d'avoir soit des heures
allongées mais surtout de
l'accessibilité les fins de
semaine. On s'assure avec eux
qu'il y a aille une augmentation
de l'offre de rendez-vous pour
la population dans les heures
défavorables qui sont plus
accessibles pour les gens sur le
marché du travail.
- Un projet-pilote de
vaccination à l'auto sera aussi
mis en place dans la grande
région de Montréal dès la
semaine prochaine.
- Il y a des belles formules qui
vont faire que ça va être très
pratique pour certaines familles
de dire : "On est quatre et on
s'en va en auto et on se fait
vacciner."
- On espère vacciner 75 % de la
population dans tous les groupes
d'âge, mais la santé publique
ne s'avance pas sur les
assouplissements qui pourraient
venir une fois l'objectif
atteint.
- Il faut pas penser à trouver
un chiffre magique; ça va être
une série de facteurs.
Il y a tellement d'inconnues
et d'impondérables, ça va
véritablement être sur le base
de notre épidémiologie. Et ça,
ça va toujours venir nous faire
ajuster notre stratégie.
- Les nouvelles sont
encourageantes, mais la
situation demeure fragile.
À preuve, une vaste portion
du Bas-St-Laurent passera sous
le coup de mesures spéciales
d'urgence dès samedi.
De nouvelles projections de
l'INSP